françois legault maintient qu'il vaut
mieux lier les tarifs d'hydro-québec à
l'inflation plutôt que de confier la
décision à la régie de l'énergie comme
par le passé le premier ministre répète
que la situation actuelle est
exceptionnelle et que son gouvernement
prendra les moyens pour limiter la
hausse des tarifs l'an prochain
je persiste et je c'est à dire que c'est
beaucoup plus simple beaucoup plus
prévisible est beaucoup plus favorable
au consommateur
d'indexer les tarifs d'hydro-québec
plutôt que d'avoir mais carey la
quittant les avec les augmentations ou
hydro québec ça nous appartient il ya du
québec là ça fait partie c'est un outil
dont on s'est doté et le premier
ministre a décidé de voter une loi qui
nous empêchent aujourd'hui de faire en
sorte qu'on est capable de retourner
l'argent dans les poches des québécois
avec nous ce soir jonathan julien le
ministre de l'énergie et des ressources
naturelles avec qui on va pouvoir faire
un point ce soir sur les tarifs
d'électricité bonsoir monsieur julien
houle et bonsoir monsieur fillon le
mécanisme que vous prévoyez pour
compenser les québécois parce que la
hausse tarifaire pourrait être de 4 5 6%
en 2023
puisque vous parlez de ce mécanisme
laisse que c'est pas la preuve que votre
loi deux ans plus tard finalement été
cohérent parce que vous déjà vous devez
déjà intervenir au pas du tout monsieur
fillion bien l'allaitement quand on a
mis en place la loi pour fixer les
tarifs d'hydroélectricité faut bien se
rappeler qu'on a maintenu la région en
place mais au lieu qu'elles fassent une
colle tarifaire sur base annuelle elle
le fait aux cinq ans dans l'intervalle
on applique l'inflation pourquoi on a
fait ce choix là pour pour deux mois de
ce fait essentielle ment avec deco
hausse tarifaire annuelle ce qu'on a
observé dans l'est dans les 15 20
dernières années c'est que une année ça
pouvait être quatre fois l'inflation
parce que c'est hydro-québec qui
présentait ses coûts à la régie est face
à ses couleurs mais le tarif est
appliqué d'autres à nice tu es la moitié
de l'inflation ce qu'on a observé
monsieur fignon sur 15 ans 20 ans j même
jusqu'à 60 ans il ya une corrélation
entre l'inflation et les tarifs mais je
travaille à des chocs tarifs ac se sont
je comprends monsieur julien m'attendais
il n'y a pas de lien entre les coûts
nécessaires les besoins d'hydro-québec
l'évaluation qu'en faisait la régie de
l'énergie et l'inflation c'est
arbitraire c'est artificiel ce lien que
vous faites avec l'inflation parce que
justement quand vous dites regardez
aujourd'hui 2013 la hausse tarifaire a
été de 2,4 alors que l'inflation était
de 0,7 2014 hausse tarifaire de 4,3
inflation de 1,4 2011 la régie de
l'énergie a annoncé une baisse une
baisse des tarifs une baisse des tarifs
de 0,4 alors que l'inflation est à 3% il
n'y a pas de lien avec l'inflation
pourquoi vous faites ce lien avec
l'inflation je peux pas être d'accord
avec vous monsieur fillion sur une
période longue c'est à dire que
momentanément une année hydro québec
peut faire lorsque le choix de faire des
investissements majeurs lohan est d'en
faire un peu moins sur 60 1 2 puis enfin
compte la nationalisation d'hydro-québec
la courbe de l'inflation aurait des
tarifs sont parfaitement coller mais
c'est ponctuée par le choix d'une course
sans me faire annuel à des quatre fois
une demi 4 x 3 x mais sur 10 ans 15 ans
20 ans une corrélation parfaite avec la
corrélation eli
lilly accidentelle peut-être je ne sais
pas et peut-être que effectivement dans
le temps ça se fait mais pour l'instant
ce que vous décidez de faire c'est de
donner de la prévisibilité dites vous
mais il ya un an mon taux d'inflation
est à 1% et ce soir il est à 5 7 % au
canada alors en quoi si vous intervenez
encore davantage en nous disant qu'en
2023 vous allez amener un mécanisme dont
on ne connaît pas la teneur ou et la
prévisibilité pour les québécois encore
là monsieur fillion vous parlez d'une
année exceptionnelle comprend les 26
dernières années avant l'année
exceptionnelle convient toujours
l'inflation était entre 0 et 3% 3 %
étant la cible maximale la banque du
canada ce qu'on observe actuellement
c'est on est en sortie de pandémie où il
ya beaucoup d'argent d'injecter dans les
systèmes ou d'epargne et où les chaînes
d'approvisionnement ont été mis à mal
donc un débalancement ponctuelles
momentanée en fin de compte de l'offre
et la demande quand même une inflation
qui est ponctuel et je dirais même
exceptionnel à situation exceptionnelle
on va prendre des mesures
exceptionnelles je comprends ok mais on
va en parler de vos mesures
exceptionnelles mais dans les faits vous
hydro québec c'est un monopole public
que le prix de l'essence que le prix des
aliments bouge et qui est un choc
inflationniste
sauf aléa jrp il on s'attend à ce que
les gouvernements aident la population
lorsque des chocs inflationniste mais
ici vous le provoqué le choc
inflationniste avec votre projet de loi
parce qu'hydro-québec ce d'un monopole
public et c'est normal d'avoir un
tribunal indépendant qui fait une
évaluation toutes les années on s'est
donné ça au québec une régie de
l'énergie vous l'avez tassé complètement
on n'a pas dansé complètement on la
ramène au 60 pour justement parce que
sur une période de 60 morts ce qu'on
observait avant monsieur fignon je le
réitère une année ça pouvait être quatre
fois l'inflation une année c'est deux
fois l'inflation donc en ayant une
période plus longue ou les causses
tarifaires sont appliquées dans
l'intervalle on a peut-être l'inflation
et la course tarifaire vient ou 60 mois
donc on vit l'iss est en réalité les
impacts à niffer en fait pendant pendant
cinq ans savoir faire ça comme ça je
veux juste montrer ça va faire ça comme
ça la régie de l'énergie en 2025 est ce
qu a voir revenir sur les cinq dernières
années qu'est ce qu'elle va faire alors
encore une fois avancé ça que ça faisait
justement quatre fois l'inflation moitié
de l'inflation l'on est venu lycée
naturellement si ce n'est de la
situation exceptionnelle aujourd'hui
après cinq ans la course tarifaire elle
regarde la structure de coûts elle
regarde la marge bénéficiaire est ce que
c'est un cos plus en sécurité c'est la
structure de coûts plus une marge
bénéficiaire est dit voici à quel niveau
devrait être fixé les tarifs pour 2025
et on constate à travers le temps 5 ans
10 ans 20 ans 60 ans c'est que en
moyenne c'est l'inflation ça va être
quoi de mécanismes le mécanisme qu'on
veut mettre en place de manière
exceptionnelle
on est en train de travailler mon
collègue des finances et moi-même sur
différents scénarios qui assurément ont
convié monsieur fillion qu'actuellement
on a cinq mois d'accumuler pour le taux
d'inflation qui va être appliqué au
rythme actuel on est à 5,2 puis en
france mon économie ce que j'avais
tantôt pense que ça va encore augmenter
alors
le mécanisme on va le connaître quand et
ça va être combien en 2023 pour les
québécois autant la prévisibilité on a
dit clairement monsieur monsieur fillion
qui aurait pas de choc tarifaire à 4 et
5% donc ça va être inférieur à 4 je
réitère que la cible des banques du
canada pour l'ipc est à 3 pour ça donc
on est ici une cible qui est connu on
voit travailler mes impressions des
mécanismes est-ce que ça va être sur la
bosse à niffer est-ce que ça va être un
bon en montagne momentanée on est à
travailler différents scénarios ce qu'on
veut s'assurer c'est que le scénario
soit équitable pour les contribuables et
éviter aussi qu'une maison une grosse
maison une petite maison l'aide
financière qui vise justement à faire
face à l'augmentation des coûts soit
équitable pour tous ok ben on a hâte
d'apprendre comment vous fonctionnez
vous le mécanisme exactement merci
beaucoup monsieur julien d'avoir un très
grand plaisir de revenir vous voir
parfait merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i see her dit